there's so many facets to this Hollywood
shipment just when you think you have it
dialed in there's something else that
comes around and they're just [ __ ]
throws your whole [ __ ] off it's
difficult it's long like I've been doing
this ship for 26 years finally getting a
shot but it was like my wife and I were
laying in bed we were watching one of
those shows like one of those behind me
music or e true Hollywood stories we
watched like four of them back-to-back
and my wife hit pause after the fourth
once it's a holy [ __ ] I figured out the
key to success and I'm like what is it
and she was like tragedy I'm like what
she was like every one of those episodes
we just watched had a had an element of
tragedy that befell the celebrity in
question and that's where celebrity
happens you can either throw in the
towel in the face of adversity or you
can use that tragedy as fuel to propel
you to the next level and I was thinking
I was like holy [ __ ] you're right and
she was like you're right and it seems
like yeah and you've never had any
tragedy in your life and I started
thinking about as I holy [ __ ] you're
right I haven't had any tragedy and so I
started looking around at all the people
that surround me and wondering who I'm
willing to let go of to make this [ __ ]
happen then two years ago it happened be
careful what you ask for because it
happened two years ago I went to
Washington DC to celebrate Thanksgiving
with my family where I'm from originally
and for me to talk about I know I went
back there and the 90 for Thanksgiving I
went out drinking with my best friends
that I grew up with and I saw my
grandma's titties that night
really guys really there's no laughs in
my face when I'm trying to open up to
you I don't know if you've ever seen
your grandma's titties but there's some
tragic [ __ ] like I'm ready to make it in
Hollywood now like I don't have ever
have you ever seen your grandma's
titties they're [ __ ] horrendous my
grandma's TVs look like to horse knows
they're all long we've a knee and once
longer than the other so it looks like a
photo finish
big brown by it knows this is how it
happened old people get up early and
[ __ ] for nothing there's no reason for
old people to get up as early as they do
I'm sneaking into my grandparents house
at 2:30 in the morning
stumbling drunk I'm trying to get in the
house to as quiet as possible to evade
the text and I open the front door my
grandmother's standing there were
face-to-face scared to sit up
my grandmother's very hunched back has
got to be Hollow because it was very
deep in the resident my grandma why are
you out of bed at 2:30 in the morning I
had no power I thought you were the
newspaper at 2:30 in the morning that
[ __ ] ain't even printed yet go back to
sleep but she won't cause when you're 93
sleep is the cousin of death so once
she's up she's up all her friends that
died died in their sleep so she ain't
Riskin is the coffee ivy just shuffle
around the house mainlining Folgers
she's up and all I want to do is just
lay down I'm like a four-year-old I'm
just like oh just go lay down stop
standing in the door will he let me past
ask me a bunch of questions who you hang
out with tonight
who was there a lot of fine young ladies
in the house what were you drinking
tonight who was on the Wheels of Steel
you're gonna wait till 2:30 in the
morning when I'm shit-faced to start
trying to relate to me so I just had to
turn the tables and start asking her a
bunch of [ __ ] up questions and make
her leave me alone
grandma how did you let your back end
higher than your head
I just want to lay down it's just why am
i able to see her back in your driver's
license picture
professionally it look like someone's
standing behind you I'm probably the
most [ __ ] up question I asked what are
we supposed to do with the funeral when
you won't lay down in the casket I'll be
telling the funeral directors it we
don't need the pillow hit we're saving
that $25 they take that pillow as long
as she hasn't touched the pillow in 17
years we're gonna have to comb her way
to the back and put her arm up on the
side we can't close the casket right now
make it look like she's a convertible
she's a tub all I want to do is just lay
down I want I'm like that I'm the type
of drunk that I just want to kick my
shoes off and fall face-first of the
pillow just knock out and that's where I
am I kick my shoes off I fall into the
pillow and I'm about to pass out and
everybody's been there where you been
hearing that a little ethereal state of
being half awake and half asleep and you
hear something that startles you awake
but you can't tell if you really heard
it or dreamt that you heard it isn't
that the scariest it in the world
especially when you're home alone on the
house locked up tight you're passing out
and almost asleep and then you hear
something
oh [ __ ] this house now if you're in your
living room and you fall asleep on the
couch and you hear noise in the living
room it wakes you up your mic what the
[ __ ] was that you might like sneak into
the other room and grab a baseball bat
or a knife or something to be like what
the [ __ ] someone in my house but
something about being asleep in bed
makes you lazy as [ __ ] for you this is
for your own safety you won't even get
out of bed you just start greeting the
potential murderer you hear a noise like
Hello does that ever stop it murder from
happening like the murderer is coming
through the house with a knife and
here's a little hello
yeah
I wasn't established [ __ ] out here but
I'm a sucker for a warm salutation that
greeting was warm as hell I was so
anyway that's where I am I'm passing out
I hear this [ __ ] I've never heard before
you can reference spent the night with
old people you know they got to get rid
of this phlegm they got a hack up these
chest clams they got to get rid of this
throat oysters got to get out after
night of jägerbomb is not the best time
you hear this for the first time I'm
passing on half of sleeping all of us on
a year I'm so disoriented it's pitch
black in the room I'm still doing this
[Applause]
I'm all the way awake now I'm under the
covers like a bee on
after like four or five minutes of
nothing happening my fear started
turning into anger and I'm getting mad
who the [ __ ] is watching Jurassic Park
247 in the morning
[Applause]
keep the cover soft stumble out into the
living room to turn the TV down if not
off and when I get out to the living
room the TV's already off that's scared
the [ __ ] out of me that told me
whatever's making those noises in the
[ __ ] house and like I said I'm
half-black and half-white at that point
my two halves completely separated the
black half of me wanted to get the [ __ ]
out of the house immediately the white
half had the insatiable urge to
investigate and the white half one I'm
inching my way down the hallway towards
the only light on in the house that's
coming out of the bathroom whatever it
is in that [ __ ] bathroom I don't even
know the prayer I'm just making up [ __ ]
I peek around into the bathroom I see
the most horrifying gruesome McCobb [ __ ]
I've ever seen in my life I see my
grandmother standing in front of the
sink wearing those horrible orthopedic
support compression stockings from the
hospital she's wearing those and that's
it soaking up longer titties banging it
the worst part is I'm seeing this happen
from the back the longest gnarliest
titties banging off the saddest ass
cheeks I've ever seen in my life
every time I'm swinging back around the
front they're grazing this think it
sounds like a full court basketball game
[Music]
I guess I was scared or startled her she
did a 180 and almost took me out was a
titties I was drunk when I moved quick
like I said one city sits lower than the
other one so I had to matrix the first
have enough time to get my timing down
to double guts the second one this is
dragging across it was Tyler now she's
just standing there looking
my grandma close the door I'm sorry baby
is the light bothering you Micheline oh
now that I'm looking at those
illuminated fun bags yeah
kill the lights they're awful like
grapefruits and tube socks you look like
a pro hacky sack player every time you
go up the steps
I did those jokes on TV don't clap now
I'm gonna get his level
I already got trouble for doing those on
television one time she saw me do those
jokes she cut and I knew I told her to
watch it was a huge mistake she called
me the next day and I just sent it to
voicemail because I knew it was it about
I didn't wanna hear it I was in a good
mood from the show I was like I'm not
listening to this [ __ ]
send it to voicemail and then later on
that night I listened to the voicemail
it was enraging it was like a minute of
her yelling at me and the worst part
about her yelling at me about doing the
jokes about her titties was that she
leaves her name at the end of the
voicemail like I have no idea who the
[ __ ] it is I guess the big reveal you
talk about my tennis for 20 goddamn
minutes on national television what the
hell is wrong with you I know you think
everything is a joke but this ain't no
joke isn't my real titties in my real
life I told all my girls from church my
church my Bible study class to watch my
grandson on TV I can't go back to my
Bible study classes all my girlfriend's
ever be called by hit gun big long titty
Margaret coming you talk about my
teacher 20 goddamn it is on national
television you need to knock that off
leave my titties in my blouse and not on
your routine and you better call me back
and let me know you got this message
this is grandma by the way
followed by her signature hang-up which
is another minute to have her trying to
hang up the phone
you